we're about to test the theory that
training your brain can improve mental
performance in the same way that
weightlifting can build muscle strength
in this game you'll have to track
several objects in motion if you happen
to be an air traffic controller or a
parent watching your kids at a busy
playground you might do well at this
game let's see how you stack up against
eagle-eyed Super Bowl quarterback Drew
Brees here are two footballs your job is
to track them as they move but we're
gonna add a bunch of other footballs
okay
[Music]
okay all right can you locate the
original two footballs drew what do you
think nine and ten nine and ten
oh nine it's Wow oh okay you want to
take your time to think drew would you
like ninety ten okay all right
take a look and see if it's nine to ten
to tell us what this tests and why Drew
is likely to be better at it than most
of us we've asked our pals at Muppet
labs for a little bit of assistance well
Hagan the task of following multiple
fast-moving objects simultaneously is a
test of several brain functions at once
vision and perception as well as spatial
awareness concentration and working
memory researchers have consistently
found high-level athletes to especially
well at tasks like this touchdown on a
giant video screen are one thing but in
order to take this to another level
we're gonna need people in panda
costumes
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly those footballs were too easy so
now we're gonna make it really tough
untrue this time he'll have to track
three different things instead of two
and buy things of course I mean dancing
pandas three of our ten pandas are
wearing blue headbands and those are the
pandas that Drew will have to track and
you can play along
fun fact they do this exact drill at NFL
training camps okay they don't really
but they should pandas show us your
headbands please mm-hmm okay okay so
drew you see those three guys over there
with the blue headbands yes those are
the three pandas we need you to keep
track of okay all right
the three pandas with the blue headbands
you ready ready
okay pandas on with your heads see what
I did there and now shuffle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it this is great all right guys
the album will be out later tonight all
right okay
pandas show us your numbers mm-hmm
audience did you follow that don't say
anything yet
don't say anything yet did you follow it
drew
uh here's I'm going I don't know I'm
going with three you know eleven I don't
there's only 10 famous exactly yeah
that's why I'm not a quarterback okay
drew which are the pandas with the blue
headbands all right I know for sure five
and ten five and ten okay I think I lost
my third but I'm gonna say number one
five ten and one yes show me five
[Applause]
and your last with me well I just
guessed
I just won't just guessed one show me
one give another guess yeah
I'm gonna go with six show us number six
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]